many cool players in our challenge uh
coming up tomorrow but now round 14 just
started pragnanda he needs points to
qualify for the knockout stage facing
jordan van forest who has been on fire i
think he's won four out of the five
previous games so this will be a tough
one for pragnanda
yeah it might be a tough one for
pregnant but he's capable he's has
beaten many of the towards top players
and he's got white
and look at the speed with which he's
been playing so far it's only move nine
white has just casted the king on move
nine uh but pregnant has got more time
than he started with he's up to 16
minutes and castling the white king here
this is still a very well known position
um it's a variation of what we call the
grunfeld defense
um if you want to know more about that
go to chessball check out peter's
fiddler's course peter svidler the
world's leading expert on the
grindfelden i'm pretty sure these two
players have studied that course because
yeah i mean every top player any
professional player who wants to delve
into this opening uh needs to check it
out and
meanwhile vampires just does capture a
pawn white normally occupies the center
with pawns in the grenfell defense but
uh black meanwhile tries to chip away at
that center from afar using pieces and
that's exactly what van forest has done
and uh okay white central pawn was under
fire it stepped forward attacking the
black knight and the black knight now on
the edge of the board
black's knight
normally we say don't go to the side
knights on the rim are dim but it can
capture a bishop at any opportunity or
can re-centralize itself so it's okay
all right and white's pawn bush stopping
the black light squad bishop coming up
and uh funnily enough i was looking at
this position i was thinking hang on a
second it's not just the gruntfeld is it
it's actually you can get this type of
position in an opening that i love which
is the kara khan and uh also via the
semi slav and this position is actually
covered in uh not just grandfather um
peter svidler's course but also by sam
shankland and his course with chesapore
on the sami slav and here he just says
because i faced this particular move
myself against the english grammar
master john erms
and sam shanklin's recommendation has
just developed the
just developed the light square bishop
at some point and black is fine
i think the
the well-known antidote at some point as
well is to trade off white's light
square bishop then trade off a night and
actually capture white central pawn just
be greedy and it's completely fine for
black but you do need to know a few
things and i think jordan may be
slightly worried that pregnant is
playing so quickly he just plays a car
move just moves his rook to the side
defending a pawn so very tense opening
still a lot of pieces left and prague
may be needing to win this one or
wanting to win this one with white to
qualify
yeah i think he's chosen a good opening
to do that cool now let's take a look at
the standings before this round
14 out of 15 in the preliminaries who is
safe who is not safe liam lehr he was
able to save that draw against magnus
carlsen and that means he is still in
the lead by three points juden from
forest is safe to qualify on 24 points
and then three points after him dingley
ran should also be safe then we have
three players now on 19 points duda
report and hans niemann and then look at
that four players on 18 points david
anton currently the last player inside
the quarter-finals david navarra is on
the same score but uh behind him on thai
breaks vedic 18 points and
pragnanda on 18 points also eric hansen
winning in the previous round
so did hari krishna they now have 15
points i mean so many players can still
qualify
this is intense that's crazy all the way
down to 13th place they're not out of it
if eric hansen or harry krishna win
their last two games
remember thai our numbers guy our stats
guy he mentioned 21 as maybe the magical
number 22 should secure qualification
21. so those players 8th to 11th place
they just need one more win out of the
last two games
ideally a bit more but yeah i mean
they will be keeping an eye maybe on the
other games it's at this point of the
tournament now they'll be keeping an eye
on other results they'll be taking risks
oh i can't wait to find out and
pragnanda so unlucky with his tie breaks
there in 11th place but uh one win and
he'll jump up and he's going to finish
off against david anton pragnanda
another player fighting in that mix um
but he's going to definitely want to win
this one with the white pieces he's
going to have the black pieces in that
final game
wow
yeah
well he has a challenge ahead of him but
uh it's one that he will himself welcome
and uh i definitely like how this has
been heating up so the line that jordan
chose was a little bit unusual and
white reacting a very normal way which
is just to develop the rook put it on an
open line and the big question for black
is how are they going to continue
development
especially the light squared bishop so
still
a lot of excitement left and well
talking about excitement i also really
like it when everyone at home joins in
the fun and joins in the action and uh
helene
says that they're watching and you can
take a look at the selfie and thanks us
for the amazing chess broadcast thank
you very much for your nice commentary
and it's a dog it is a dog we do like
dogs don't we oh yeah absolutely and uh
mirzarek is covered watching oh
well you know good things bad things we
hope you get well soon absolutely yeah
definitely
and uh if you two want to send us your
questions your thoughts and your selfies
remember in landscape mode is best then
you can always tweet us using the
hashtag chestchamps
okay and as you predicted and uh as you
mentioned sam shankland in his chessable
course advocated black's bishop has just
come out to a decent square
it can get hit maybe by a pawn by a
night later but for now this bishop is
active the bishop also has cleared a
path for the rook in the corner to slide
across to the nice open sea file
and uh for a logical move i'm expecting
white's dart squad bishop to come out
it's all about peace development all
about who can get active the quickest
and uh i expect prague after a minute or
two of thinking to bring out his dark
square bishop it was quite choices it
was quite funny because when you said uh
it can get hit i was like oh yeah let's
look at what the main move is main move
is actually attacking that bishop right
now with the pawn with the pawn and
that's a really brave stuff because you
know traditionally
you don't want to be doing those type of
things you know weakening your own king
but here it seems to be this is the move
of choice yeah i think prague might
regret it if he doesn't get very very
aggressive shortly and start taking
those risks so throwing a pawn forward
even in front of your own king attacking
a bishop would make a lot of sense with
the tournament situation in mind of
course and please don't forget our
fundraiser for unicef chess24.com
slash donate we did have leakage here in
the studio he has experience being in
war um as a child himself the sound of
war the sirens ringing being in bomb
shelters being a refugee fleeing from
war the fear
children in ukraine is going through
this now
and
the only thing we can do to help is
help the organizations that is
in ukraine and around ukraine so please
help us help unicef do their uh work
their life saving work by donating and
we have
crossed sixty thousand dollars
so please just continue donating it is
helping
i actually heard um the last number from
unicef they have shipped down
800 tons of supplies to the people and
the refugee refugees
so it is helping
what we're doing 63 thousand dollars and
of course the auction for david's chess
lesson as well let's see it's up to 650
dollars
incredible yeah uh you know thank you to
everyone who is bidding thank you to
everyone who's donating i mean really
it kind of warms my heart and it just
kind of also feels like the chess
community are just clubbing together and
we are forming a nice community and just
making sure that we can help
everyone in the ukraine and yeah i i was
also
listening to leo's story and the story
about the sirens really had an impact on
me i mean i hadn't even thought about
that i mean that's how kind of like
privileged we are that we're living in a
comfortable place and it's just by luck
that we're here right and we are not the
ones
in somewhere else where things are bad
exactly yeah
just the sound of those sirens being a
kid
i mean you're supposed to watch children
television going to sleep and then
you have to run down to a bomb shelter
it's just
wrong
yeah it could be traumatizing and that's
why unicef i mean they're doing work not
just with resources uh but also
psychological physical help and the kids
they really need it can't imagine uh
what they're going through yeah
and uh okay meanwhile still a long think
from pregnant under
uh three and a half minutes at this
point and
still a very standard move from black so
it's a bit surprising he's thinking he's
feeling the nerves of the tournament
situation it's the big momentous
occasion it's this one moment as well
it's almost a must win game for him
because uh okay he's got another
opportunity in the last round but a win
here and he'd be on the brink of
qualifying so
um also it's a stylistic thing i think
it's not his style to throw pawns
forward and get really ambitious this
early in the game he likes to kind of
assert control first and then take his
chances and then go on the
offensive but
maybe now is the moment and it's an
early stage
and maybe he just has to fight against
his natural instincts and go for it and
okay i thought he was about to make a
move just from his body language there
but uh while he thinks while he
scratches his head maybe we can jump in
because this is a big moment it's just
after the opening both sides of castled
signifying the end of the opening and uh
now to push or not to push that is the
question throw this pawn forward attack
the black bishop force it back to a bad
square the bishop has to go back where
it came from
the problem is for white you've weakened
yourself you've loosened with this he
goes for it what a player
so brave and uh he just spent a couple
of minutes blocking up that courage and
i think he's made the right decision so
you have loosened your king as i
mentioned this pawn isn't ideal out
there but you can bring pieces to the
defense of your king you can cover a lot
of squares for example you can jump
forward with your bishop now um you can
maybe jump into the center with your
knight later on you still have a nice
open line you have a bit more space
because your pawn in the center cramps
black's position and
still yes your king is open
pawn wants to be further back but black
never really is able to organize an
attack against it so i think he's made a
good decision seizing space kicking
jordan's pieces back and showing his
ambitions and i have to say you always
teach me david and iran go take centers
start the game by taking center where is
the black pieces in the center here yeah
they're going to attack
they're just dropping the part about
taking center and going straight into
attack yeah they're just so you have two
kind of approaches in chess you can
control the center that is kind of like
the classical way how people play it or
you can kind of play in a little bit
more modern way which is simply you let
your opponent take the center and then
what you do is you restrain that sensor
from advancing and then you use your
pieces to attack so what black's plan in
this
position is uh
first of all he has to deal with white's
initiative and then
once he's dealt with that he's going to
probably try to undermine the center and
just try to open up the position
and uh finally if he can't do that then
he has to
i'm trying to think of a way to to
actually attack the center with the
pieces and in this particular one it's
actually very difficult to see a way to
do it it's very difficult i mean on
paper black has a great position right
you have this nice bishop um and
actually i think you mentioned the word
modern ivanka they called the grunfeld
one of the hyper-modern openings because
it was a bit of a revolutionary one when
it was first discovered because you
don't occupy the central tool you hit
the center from afar so this bishop kind
of cuts across on the dart squares
this knight controls the central pawn
from afar at least keeps an eye on it
and you wait until the right moment and
then you break forward with your pawn so
one pawn break would be here pushing
forward undermining white's pride and
joy the central d-pawn which is actually
isolated another idea could be pushing
forward the f pawn trying to break open
white structure on the king's side and
uh yeah it's very much a hyper-modern
type of approach it's not classical
thinking it's not occupying the center
not going for those general rules but
there are ideas behind black's grenfell
setup that's one reason i recommend
chessable
his grandfather of course he explains
how you can fight for the center by not
necessarily controlling it with pawns
it's from afar with your bishops with
your knights and uh talking about
fighting for center white bishop did
step forward
this is actually black's most central
pawn doesn't look impressive but as i
mentioned it would love to step forward
and challenge white in the middle of the
board and prague has prevented that by
creating a pin on this diagonal stopping
any active play so that's the fight
right now black would love to undermine
white's center but he's unable to do so
and okay the bishop kicked back and the
bishop just retreats so yeah i was
saying black on paper has a perfect
position this is unisolated porn these
are doubled pawns this pawn a bit weak
as well the white king's so weak but
look at black's pieces they're cramped
this knight is completely dominated by
pawns this rook has to
kind of be stuck defending it the pawn
in front of it because white actually
has an open line here white has an open
line here white has a nice bishop pin
white is active black is passive yeah
and i'm expecting to see maybe black
continue with that passivity maybe
re-rooting the knight in front of
the isolated pawn that's good strategy
as well but
would you prefer here your anchor
um i like white's position actually
and you forgot one other thing that
black has on paper that's meant to be
amazing the bishop bishop
but uh i agree it's just like there's
not enough space this big pawn that's
sitting in the center that i know that
chesapeal author uh jonathan rousen of
the seven deadly chess scenes he calls
it delroy which is a name i've never
liked but he kind of says you know this
born is just clamping down black's
position and it's not easy
and i think
i'm not 100 sure on this but uh when i
read jonathan's rousing's book actually
understand wow okay chaos on the board
we'll explain that in a moment in a
moment but when i read rousey's book he
called this whole line delroy's granite
statue because it's just so strong and
earlier white had supported it with
another pawn but coming back to this
position we both gasped a bit because
black now is exploding things open now
it's complete chaos the evaluation bar
hates this for black um he's trying to
however undermine the structure in front
of white's king
and ivanka i think white should just
ignore this yeah i'm just thinking
ignore that ignore that consequence
consequence and i'm thinking put the
bishop on to the santa square
and it looks like this loses a pawn it
looks like it sacrifices a pawn because
black now can capture supported by its
bishop but after bishop takes bishop
yeah you lure out the black king and
suddenly there are nasty checks and look
how open this king is how lonely it is
no defenders around it checkmate's just
coming already i think wow like the
black king once it steps back the white
knight can jump in
it looks scary super scary such a
reckless move from jordan because you
know his position didn't demand it
wasn't ready for this activity instead
he needed to kind of kind of grimace a
little bit and go backwards and maneuver
his pieces a little bit uh this
way too soon and the consequences he's
weak in the dark squares i just think
put the bishop in the middle and it's
natural just looking else it's the only
move to get the advantage okay
this is the move we're looking for
planting the bishop in the center of the
warden as you mentioned it's natural
that's for two reasons one if you leave
the bishop here then it might get locked
in the what black pawn will come and
attack it so you don't want your bishop
locked in and the other reason maybe the
only other natural move is to capture
this pawn but suddenly blacks attack uh
well i would say attack quite generously
here but at least black gets an active
threat against this pawn so uh yeah the
most natural move in the position the
one your first instinct ivanka
very very strong planting the bishop in
also it's logical get rid of your
opponent's only defender of the black
king
and it's going to be one side of traffic
i think jordan's king is gonna be under
heavy fire for the rest of the middle
game if prague finds this key move
bishop to e5 and uh let's go back to the
players is he gonna find it
if he does he might win this game and he
might qualify for the oh wow what a
moment for pragnanda
in the tournament
thinking for two minutes this must be a
great time to take that time to think
now is the time it's a critical moment
and you know because jordan has actually
changed the nature of the position
before it was kind of dynamic but
maneuvering and it was still relatively
quiet now it's chaos on the board and
you have to adapt to that shift
and yeah i just do you think i mean the
expression
mana from heaven will probably be
crossing pragananda's mind you'll be
like oh my god i've been just gifted
this golden opportunity
just to
just to get uh jordan on the back foot
and are we looking for like that one
move from pregnant everything else at
least let's jordan back in the game now
is the moment you've got to seize this
opportunity while black pieces are kind
of distracted and on passive squares you
have to go on attack against the black
king involving removing the black bishop
in front of it so just trade off that
black bishop the black dart squad bishop
and uh yeah big attack and i mean in
order to become a grand master what was
it 12 13 years old like prague you have
to have good instincts it's not
necessarily about the moves but it's
about sensing the critical moments and
his instincts have paid off he's
thinking right now but he needs to find
this move yeah and uh yeah as you
mentioned ivanka it's one of the most
natural moves maybe one of the top two
most natural moves okay i think he's
just trying to work out
maybe he's just shocked that jordan's
gone for this maybe he's trying to work
out how black can defend and what to do
next but
i think within the next minute or two
he's got to make a decision
and he's just got to go for it
everything else he's itching for it yeah
you can see on the on the camera uh his
spidey sensors tingling yeah you can see
that you know this felt like a really
unnatural move uh i must admit david
when you were saying you certainly got
one chance one shot eminem flashed into
my mind oh he doesn't play he doesn't
play it he went for the other move i
mentioned also natural trading instead
of pawns but suddenly the black light
squad bishop is allowed out
and this one's more double-edged this
one's not so easy is it still possible
though he's still got the advantage i
think he should maybe just continue with
the same plan we highlighted um it's
just less effective now because black
light squared bishop is more active than
it was and the light squared bishop can
actually help to defend the black king
also pointing towards some pawns near
the white king so
so why did prague go for this what could
be his plan we can see on him he's he's
shaking that he is you know sensing that
he is having an advantage i think maybe
just a little bit of nerves i i think he
would have gone
for sure he would have gone for the
other move if he had 10 15 minutes on
his clock if it was just round one of
the tournament but maybe he didn't maybe
he thought he was losing a pawn in the
process we showed he wasn't but uh maybe
he just thought okay this is the safer
option uh now though he needs to play
with energy before the black pieces do
start to come to life jordan's suddenly
looking a bit more focused yeah a bit
more happy so
okay
i'm expecting the bishop to still plonk
itself in the center maybe white's
knight can move
yeah i mean it's the only move that
makes sense because otherwise
jordan's gamble has paid off i mean if
you just step forward passively with
your king
well then
black benefited from this pawn trade
instead you need to shake the black
position of get bit and the only way to
do that is by targeting the defenders
and trade-off dark square bishops he's
got to do it the thing is that i'm a
little bit concerned about the time
because he's only got five minutes
whereas jordan has 10 minutes and things
are still to heat up even more so he
needs to leave himself a little margin
for this these complications and it's
not just the fact that
he's getting low on the clock but he
didn't find it the first time this
bishop moved
he finds it the second time though craig
okay still reasserting his advantage
it's not as strong as it would have been
but it's still a strong move and okay
the evaluation but i'm expecting to go
slightly back more in white's favor
because i think that was a good move
and uh it's logical for two reasons
eliminating the black dark squad bishop
as a defender black's king very airy
very open but also if your opponent has
the bishop pair trade one of those
bishops off and at least on the dark
squares black is vulnerable uh once his
bishop is removed
so okay jordan needs to be really
creative defensively here in order to
even survive the next few moves so okay
prague invested that time well at least
on this time
yeah wow
well at least uh the excitement over the
board is cheering everyone up and uh
well people at home are watching and uh
poor doran alone
who is suffer is sick
but they've got their blanket and
they're watching us so they're already
feeling better you're welcome i mean
that's what i like to hear and well we
see bishop takes the pawn so things are
really really computer that move by
jordan okay that means
yeah it looks pretty bad and i i'm not
sure it loses on the spot but
strategically it's bad um i think white
just gets a big big attack it's okay he
trades bishops and brings his queen up
this is
by far the most natural move for white
and i think also by far the strongest
okay and look at that black king it's
simply because black lacks defenders and
jordan i think he's underestimated his
opponents attacking resources and
wow look at this oh wow only one move to
stay in the game any black king this is
czech black's king attacked by the white
queen any king move loses almost
instantly white will be able to bring
knights into the game into the attack
rooks into the attack the king is just
doomed he has to throw a pawn in the way
but it's not obvious
you just basically give back the pawn
you just grabbed for free and uh he has
to find this jordan he'll calculate for
a while but
black has to push his pawn forward to
two squares to block this track pawn to
e5
oh do you think he's going to find it
your anchor i think the whole reason as
well is that the black queen can use a
diagonal to come and block some tracks
and because because of this queen move
actually i think you will find it
because the alternative looks quite bad
you know if the black king steps back
then i i was instinctively thinking of
just pushing taking going backwards with
my queen to dive in and shall we jump in
let's keep an eye on the players as well
while we investigate the move because
it's a key moment black has to push his
pawn forward two squares to block this
annoying check so if he does this pushes
the pawn forward
oh actually just to show why the
alternatives are bad ivanka you
mentioned this move if the king steps
backwards or moves on to a light square
i thought oh you know the queen can come
and
slide back
and uh also i was thinking of john
nunn's little motto which is like lose
pieces drop off and i was thinking of
targeting that bishop this piece is also
loose so for example if black stops the
invasion of the white queen by bringing
the king forward you can just leap in
with your knight two deadly threats
firstly just winning a bishop getting
greedy secondly more importantly you're
gonna jump in with the queen now
supported by this knight and that would
end in checkmate in a couple of moves so
the king move would lose instantly it
would lose at least a bishop maybe even
to checkmate so the king going back
would lose you have to block but the
reason i think maybe this isn't obvious
for jordan is because after rook takes
pawn there's still a problem still the
white queen is trying to break through
to the king and if you throw your queen
in the way now which is maybe the idea
behind giving up this pawn if the black
queen jumps in the way
kind of
re uh kind of reinforcing this diagonal
then white can just leap forward with
the knight and hit the queen once the
queen moves for example if it captures
this knight looks like black's
threatening checkmate but no white is
the one to deliver checkmate first brook
takes pawn is a double check
with the rook and queen double checks
you have to move your king no matter
where you go queen to the this square
the g7 square kiss of death checkmate
and uh this ends the game so even if he
finds the best move now jordan which
he's spending a long long time on even
if he finds that he has to push this
pawn in the way he's still in big
trouble
and he has to be precise as well with
his defense
um
i still think he will find it just
because i think the alternatives are not
that great the other moves just lose
instantly and it's very basic actually
yeah
so i think you'll find it just
through a process of elimination and
you'll just go okay fine whatever best
this is the one i don't maybe see an
immediate loss to because often that's
the best principle when you're defending
such a terrible position such as this
you're like okay
here i spot the win for white here i
don't
here i spot a win for white but here
maybe i'm still fighting so you choose
that one it's very much a defensive form
of thinking yeah i mean these top
players that we have in the field here
all 16 of them if you give them a
position where there's only one move to
find more often than not they will find
it as your mike mentions process of
elimination or
just pure calculation
but yeah this one it's not
oh it's not easy the psychological blow
for jordan maybe now just the
realization that he's in big trouble
that's maybe another hurdle for him to
overcome also spending four minutes on
the clock
times nearly level again and it's always
easier to be on the attacking side when
you're low on time than the defensive
side so uh looking good for prague all
of those factors wow and uh jordan pham
forest on 24 points he should be
qualified for the court final so this is
not dramatic for him in that sense
pragnanda if he wins this game will be
on 21 points with one more round to go
that will probably take him inside top
eight but
so many players are currently
fighting for qualification to the
knockout i think the bar is slightly
over to hans niemann side in his game
against hari krishna hansen eric hansen
he
the chances are small for him but
winning the gear first game today
he is in contention the bar roughly in
the middle in his game against judah he
needs to win this game eric hansen need
it
he needs
he needs points definitely bar slightly
to the middle in his game against ding
magnus carl isn't currently fighting
against joe and jun i think it's looking
good for the world champion
liam
looking quite good for him in his game
for against navara navara is fighting to
qualify
richard report
bar over to his side that's good news
for him he uh will need some points to
feel safe
and david anton he also needs
points to qualify
basically in all the games
there are players fighting for
qualification and some big matchups uh
kaya you mentioned it's looking good for
the world champion but which world
champion because that's true
the chess world champion against the
women's world champion big big clash but
yeah looking good magnus in that one
yeah let's let's take a quick look just
at the standings just to remind everyone
about the drama here with this round and
only one more round to go pragnanda on
18 points outside top eight but a win
here will take him to 21 points and if
he is a little bit lucky with results in
the other game that's definitely gonna
take him inside
top eight for now with only one round to
go
i mean it's impossible to say who's
going to qualify yeah
i mean i'm definitely not a betting man
in general but this type of field when
it's so bunched up so close you can't
make any bets because uh i mean it could
all be decided by one move one blunder
and uh i mean we're talking about
blunders uh vampires definitely making
mistakes and he's frozen he's spent six
and a half minutes now on this move he
realizes he's on the brink of defeat
already and it's only moved 22. and is
it like even if he finds he finds that
move he finds the best
is it still not looking great still not
looking good at all for black we showed
one variation of course prague was
thinking in van furst time which is a
great tip and he moves instantly so he's
up the speed pressure back on van forest
and he can't throw his queen in the way
of this diagonal as we showed a few
moments ago
if he blocks with the queen i think that
would lose on the spot
so does he have to move the black king
he doesn't move the black king off the
diagonal
but still white's knights are flooding
forward and uh okay it's a nice line
right if the knight were to
join the party as we say
yeah and i think anything could join the
party here look at white's rook in the
bottom corner as well that piece idle
not really participating you could swing
that piece across that looks super
strong as uh as i mentioned also the
white knight on the left side that could
centralize itself
with so many tempting i love the knight
centralizing itself do you know look at
jordan head in his hands
he thinks he's losing he knows he's
losing
yeah he knows this has all gone totally
wrong
uh
i mean the only thing that i can see and
it does require pragananda to help him
is that the queen the black queen
manages to magically transfer herself
and plant herself on the square right
next to the king so
so that's the only move i can think of
that can kind of
just shore up the desert defenses yeah
kind of keep the king in check and the
more i look at it
the more i think there's just too many
tempting moves here for prague i was
mentioning this rook doing nothing bring
it to the party invited in and uh after
a rook trade here i mean you can even
you can capture with anything you can
capture with your rook to try and bring
it into the game you can capture with
your knight maybe even more tempting and
uh yeah this pawn is pushing forward
this knight is flooding in this looks
good you could also as you mankind
mentioned bring this knight in looks
super strong as well and there's another
hinting at some checks um you're
threatening to play rook takes rook and
then jump in with a knight check or even
flip the order this knight check looks
deadly um another tempting option sorry
in this position it's just maybe bring
your queen across that using this idea
i'm borrowing from you earlier ivanka
just trying to creep into the black king
position
pregnant probably has three or four
winning moves and sometimes that is when
mistakes happen you're just spoiled for
choice and you end up thinking too long
you get indecisive and uh yeah here
perfectionism is not important just
bring a piece into the game and uh
pregnant should win so let's go back to
the players either the queen move the
night move or even a rook move and he
should win this game but
for choice yes for choice but uh having
said that you know he's been in this
type of situation before and i'm
primarily thinking of his game against
magnus carlsen where he was given the
opportunity to win the game
and he was ruthless
really ruthless and when he beat me when
he was 12 years old he was also ruthless
so yeah pregnant
uh on the brink here just needs to not
let the time become his nemesis
not let himself tick under to
even one minute because then he might
get a bit nervous he might normally uh
when i get nervous i take safety first
options and that's not what this
position requires it requires ammunition
keep pedaling on that bike and okay he
plays that third option that i mentioned
swinging the queen across and i like
this as well because black's queen now
cannot cover that magical g6 square that
the white queen wants to use the black
queen tied down to her rook yeah
and uh
actually that's it's a really
devastating threat that uh pragnanda has
just to
slide the queen two squares forward on
the diagonal and give a check to the
king yeah i must admit that wouldn't
have been on my radar normally but i
stole the idea from you a few moves ago
and pregnant clearly had done the same
he spotted that this was an idea five
moves ago or four moves ago and he's
played it now and it looks equally
strong i actually borrowed it from
magnus yesterday in his game against
actually
that's instructive i mean top players we
just borrow ideas from everywhere right
it's all about pattern recognition and
that magnus game yesterday was different
but it's similar idea and uh
it's uh that's how we kind of we talk
about creativity but the more research
you do the more games you watch the more
creative you become because you have a
whole bunch of ideas in your mind and
okay black's king comes back to where it
came from just to stop white's queen
sneaking in
at the very least now pregnant could
just repeat the position once bring his
queen back where it came from as well
just gain 10 seconds on the clock and
then choose another option
but
yeah ideally he needs to decide now one
minute 40. and well speaking of magnus
carlsen three points he won his game
against the women's world champion ju
wen jun that's going to take magnus too
the same score as liam oh
sorry
what is this
just to have this move on your radar is
incredible we were looking at the king
side we were looking at the black king
he just picked up his rook in the corner
and threw it up the board sacrificing it
in this angle
and that rook can just be captured but
his idea is that the black rook in the
corner indirectly defends its other rook
in the center of the board
i mean
he's too good for this age yeah what a
player
just to use all the sides of the board
just like that i mean incredible yeah
yeah we have to show this yeah we
definitely just keep an eye on the
players because this move rook takes a7
was not on our radar we thought okay
it's all about the black king we were
looking at bringing the rook this way
maybe uh maybe bringing this knight or
this knight into the game he just
thought okay this rook in the corner is
overloaded to even see this to even
cross your mind this is genius but rook
takes pawn wins a pawn now uh because
now this rook as mentioned indirectly
defends the rook in the cor in the
center if you take the white rook looks
like a free piece but suddenly you look
lose your rook in the middle and this is
just game over the queen and the rook
will combine to deliver checkmate to the
black king and uh what else can black
try uh if you don't capture the white
rook it's simply going to take this pawn
and break through on the seventh rank
equally deadly if you capture white's
rook in the center then at the very
least you can take this pawn but now you
can capture also this rook with your
queen with your knight
anything and white is simply winning
next move the rook's gonna take this
pawn it's just game over and okay he
chooses this way but is this the
leicester evil i don't know it just
looks like checkmate coming all white
needs to do now is flicking a check and
this is going to be going over the king
defenseless pregnant about to win an
amazing victory look at that evaluation
bar plus seven just give this check you
can maybe even bring okay you can't
bring your knight in there is a threat
of the rook coming down and uh harassing
your king so you need to be a bit quick
but i think this check i mean it's the
first one that came to my mind diagonal
checks with the queens and
yeah no hiding spot uh for example queen
check the king will move across and very
minimum you just drop back now night
check is coming it's game over
wow
16 year old pragnanda a month ago he
wrote history when he became the
youngest player to win a game against
magnus carlsen after he became world
champion
this time he is fighting for
qualification in a super strong
tournament and on his way
playing genius
yeah this is true genius i mean that
rook move i think even if i had half an
hour
i'm not sure i would have even
considered it and it was super strong as
we see with the evaluation bar just
immediately winning on the spot yeah
it's just very creative uh i mean
like i said you know it's so easy just
to be focused on where the action is and
then just to kind of take that step back
and find a different move but with the
still very much the same kind of point
but on a different side of the board
it's just amazing and uh following
david's rule diagonal checks with the
queen are very very difficult to parry
we learned that yesterday yeah and it
was true yeah and it's true here because
this check cannot be blocked by the
black queen if the black queen does
slide across and offer a trade then
white's rook will actually give itself
up with a nasty check and the black king
will be distracted the black queen will
fall
so this is just winning on the spot and
it's all about that full board vision
okay
wow okay putting his queen in the corner
that's not what i expected i thought he
would just bring his rook back and stop
this check but pragnanda has this one
covered the check from the black rook
looks like checkmate but no the knight
drops back and it's guarded by its rook
at the top of the board i mean pregnant
he used all the angles he used this a7
square on the left side he's in the
corner on this side he's dropping his
knight back to the bottom of the board
he's literally played on all four sides
of the board in order to win this game
and it's simply a checkmate threat from
the white queen and white rook over the
next couple of moves and
black dude blacks rook is just
i mean not participating anymore because
white's regarding its knight at the
bottom of the board you asked the
question what to do my
solution is resign yeah i think we'll
see one or two more moves from jordan he
never really resigns uh from my
experience okay the black king trying to
find a safe haven amongst its own pawns
logical but now
okay there must be a killer blow what is
the finishing touch now for prague
37 seconds and a super important win for
hans niemann taking him to
isn't it 21 points i think hans niemann
will now have it's looking good for the
18 year old american to qualify for the
knockout stage
and okay some queen checks available to
white very least again just because i'm
a pragmatist i would bring my queen back
to the center of the board
but okay he gives a check
allowing the black king to hide
on the side okay what is this idea
because now black threatens checkmate in
one rook takes knight will be checkmate
if and whoa okay crazy tactics prague is
just showing off now with some nice
geometry and i think we're about to see
a result because king takes rook now
it's a check king takes rook would walk
into a night fork white's knight will
plant itself in the center checking the
black king and winning the black queen
this this is just one of the most
beautiful games i've ever seen let alone
on the tour it's just a masterpiece
it's just fireworks non-stop every move
is a really crazy unexpected blow it's a
lesson in calculation right and tactical
motifs i mean that rook check and the
rook takes pawn sacrificing material and
all to get this this particular night
fork
and we are definitely gonna see it and i
think i saw a little mini fist pump from
pragananda and we have a result this
night fork winning the black queen ends
in van forest
resignation i guess it's applause
i mean to pregnant
we throw the coins yeah and we say well
done i know it's incredible